[Musik]
es wäre nur eine Frage von ein paar
Stunden bis zur Entscheidung innerhalb
nur wenige Tage würde die Ukraine
vollständig unter seiner Kontrolle sein
nach seinen Plänen wäre die russische
Armee mit voller Geschwindigkeit
vorgerückt und hätte Kiew innerhalb
weniger Tage eingenommen selenski und
seine Regierung während aus der
Hauptstadt geflohen die ukrainische
Armee hätte kapituliert und nach ein
paar Tagen wäre alles bereit für die
große Siegesparade gewesen holt den
träumte davon eine große militärische
und historische Heldentat so vollbringen
und die Ukraine wieder unter die Fuchtel
des russischen Mutterlandes zu bringen
wir haben dort auch so einige Parade
Uniform gefunden das heißt sie haben
erwartet dass sie hier in zwei Tagen
erreichen und dann hier eine Parade
abhalten deswegen können wir jetzt sagen
dass wir Ihre Pläne komplett zu nicht
der gemacht haben Alex
stellvertrie Staatschef des Kommandos
der ukrainischen Bodentruppen doch
Putins Träume und der reale Verlauf der
Ereignisse hätten nicht
unterschiedlicher sein können die
Ukraine erhielten allen Widrigkeiten zum
Trotz stand internationale Hilfe traf
ihn vorher kaum vorstellbarem Ausmaß ein
und die russische Armee erwies sich als
noch löchriger als ein Schweizer Käse
und das Ergebnis nicht nur dass die
russische Siegesparade in Kiew ausfallen
musste nein ein Jahr später tobte der
Krieg noch immer und Russland hat enorme
Verluste zu beklagen sowohl an Material
als auch an Menschenleben
[Musik]
nach vorliegenden Schätzungen wurden
allein im ersten Jahr der Invasion mehr
als 180.000 russische Soldaten getötet
oder verwundet wir sprechen hier also
von durchschnittlich fast 500 Verlusten
pro Tag wobei ein Verlust nicht
automatisch eingefallen sein muss auch
verletzte gefangen genommen und der
septierte Soldaten sind für Putins Armee
verloren darüber hinaus hat die
russische Armee in nur 12 Monaten Krieg
mehr Generäle und hochrangige Offiziere
verloren als in Jahren Syrien Krieg oder
mehr als die Sowjets während ihres
zehnjährigen Krieges in Afghanistan die
Russen mussten auf blutige Weise
feststellen dass es doch eben etwas ganz
anderes ist gegen eine zumindest
rudimentär nach nato-maßstäben
vorbereitete Armee eines europäischen
Landes zu kämpfen als gegen
Aufständische im Nahen Osten erschweren
kommt hinzu dass die empfindlichsten
Verluste vor allem unter den am besten
ausgebildeten russischen Einheiten
verzeichnet wurden beispielsweise den
Luft Landetruppen und der Marine
entfanterie aber das meine Lieben
Zuschauer ist noch nicht das Ende der
Fahnenstange schaut euch diese Nachricht
an Russland hat Schätzungen zur Folge
wahrscheinlich mehr als die Hälfte
seiner Panzer in der Ukraine verloren
wir sprechen hier von mehr als
2300 Panzern insgesamt könnte Russland
nach einer Zählung des britischen
Geheimdienstes alleine im ersten
Kriegsjahr mehr als 4.500 gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge aller Art 63 Flugzeuge 70
Hubschrauber 12 Marineschiffe und
hunderte von Artillerie System verloren
haben und dabei sind nur die Verluste
berücksichtigt die relativ gut
dokumentiert sind mit anderen Worten die
Invasion war für den Kreml eine echte
Katastrophe und was für eine
aus aller verzweifelten Versuche und zum
großen Erstaunen aller nato-armeen war
Russland nicht einmal in der Lage
verkiff einzunehmen eine Stadt die
immerhin nur 50 km von der russischen
Grenze entfernt liegt und eines der
Hauptziel der Invasion darstellte das
soll nicht heißen dass die Russen keine
Verheerungen anrichten es stimmt das
Putin mit seiner Raketen und seine
Artillerie die Ukraine zerstört und
Städte wie Mario
polzerodoniewsknabachmut und viele
weitere Intruder Wüsten verwandelt hat
aber wisst ihr was trotz alter
Zerstörung die er über die Ukraine
gebracht hat und trotz aller Verluste
die die russische Armee für seine
Ambitionen bezahlen musste hat Putin
nicht ein einziges seiner Hauptziel
erreicht selenskis Regierung scheint
stärker die nicht zu sein die
vermeintliche Vereinigung der slawischen
Bruder Völker durch Gewalt war ein
durchschlagender misser Erfolg die
Ukraine ist nicht gefallen und so alle
Überfluss sind ihre Beziehungen zu
Westen heute viel stärker und ihre Armee
ist viel moderner bewaffnet als es noch
vor einem Jahr der Fall
warst du
und all jene Ukraine die sich zuvor der
Illusion über eine friedliches
Miteinander mit den Russen hingegeben
hatten sind zutiefst geschockt
angesichts der Gleichgültigkeit oder gar
Euphorie die eine große Zahl ihrer
Nachbarin im Osten gegenüber den durch
die russische Armee begangenen
Grausamkeit unserer Störungen empfindet
nicht umsonst schrieb uns einer unserer
Zuschauer folgendes
die schiere Menge an zustimmenden und
jubelnden Kommentaren gewöhnlicher
Russen unter Videos über die Gräueltaten
die an Zivilisten in der Ukraine
begangen wurden waren für die Ukraine
nicht weniger schockierend als der Krieg
selbst wir haben uns irgendwie an den
Krieg gewöhnt aber die Erkenntnis nehmen
wem wir die ganze Zeit gelebt haben ohne
es überhaupt zu wissen ist immer noch
erschreckend klar nicht zufällig nennen
sie sich gegenseitig nur Brüder nicht
Freunde letztere kann man sich im
Gegensatz zu seiner bösartigen
Verwandtschaft schließlich aussuchen
umgekehrt dürfte jetzt aber auch so gut
wie jedem Russen klar geworden sein dass
die Ukraine nur erst recht keinen Bock
darauf haben mit Ihnen in einem Staat
unter Putin leben zu wollen und sich
deswegen umso erbitterter zu werden der
Traum von dieser Völkerfreundschaft ist
für den nächsten Generationen erstmal
ausgeträumt selbst wenn die Russen also
die Ukraine doch noch irgendwie schlagen
und besetzen sollten während sie nicht
in der Lage die massive Ablehnung und
den Widerstand ihnen gegenüber zu
bändigen sie würden auf einem Westen
lässt sitzen gegen dass das
Tschetschenien der 90er Jahre wirkt wie
ein häkelkreis im russischen
kaukasischen freundschaftsvereine und
wenn der Krieg schon zu einem
unbeherrschbaren Albtraum für die Russen
geworden ist was wäre dann die
Besatzungsherrschaft aber bedeutet dies
alles nur dass der russische Diktator
bleibt und zum Einlenken bereits sein
könnte
[Applaus]
nun bis jetzt macht er jedenfalls nicht
den Eindruck ein Jahr nach der Invasion
hat Russland nach Angaben des britischen
Verteidigungsministers Ben Wolles 97%
seiner derzeitig verfügbaren
Kampftruppen im Ukraine Krieg im Einsatz
und trotzdem scheint er Sieg für keine
Seite im greifbarer Nähe zu sein weder
für die Russen noch für die Ukraine die
große Frage die allen unter den
Fingernägeln brennt ist also wie um
alles in der Welt diese Hölle enden wird
wie kann der Krieg in der Ukraine zu
Ende gebracht werden welches Szenarien
haben die großen internationalen Akteure
auf den Tisch liegen gibt es überhaupt
irgendwelche Gewissheiten bezüglich der
Zukunft der Ukraine keine Angst das
alles werden wir in diesem Video
ausgiebig beleuchten und zwar gleich
nachdem ich euch unsere neuen Sponsor
vorgestellt habe ein Sponsor auf den ich
mich ganz besonders gefreut haben
Holzkern denn vielleicht ist euch
aufgefallen dass heute etwas anders an
mir ist ganz genau dieses schmucke Stück
Holzkern hat nach 20 Jahren meine
Begeisterung für Ohren wieder zum Leben
erweckt ja stimmt während meiner
Schulzeit konnte ich mir nicht
vorstellen ohne Uhr am Handgelenk außer
Haus zu gehen aber dann bin ich doch zu
einem uhrenmuffel geworden Uhrzeit kann
man ja am Handy ablesen und irgendwie
hatten die damalige uhrenmode auch nicht
besonders zugesagt so jetzt bin ich
jedoch auf Holzkern gestoßen und naja
seht sie euch einfach an also ich
persönlich bin der Meinung dass dieses
naturverbundene Design dieser kernige
Charakter einfach zu mir passt oder was
bei dir schon wann Auspacken das
natürlich versandkostenfreien Päckchens
merkt man dass sich die österreichische
Firma Holz kann ganz besondere Mühe gibt
damit wirklich jede Facette eures Uhren
Erlebnis ist perfekt und gleichzeitig
herrlich naturlich ist und dann fallen
einem natürlich die eigentlichen
Materialien aus denen nur gefertigt ist
ins Auge ihre Maserung Marmorierung und
das Schülern von Holz Stein und permut
jedes Stück ist von Natur aus ein Unikat
die Natur Verbundenheit von Holzkern
zeigt sich jedoch nicht nur in ihren
Produkten selbst dann auch darin dass
ihre Herstellung Verpackung und die
Lieferketten so nachhaltig wie möglich
gehalten sind und darüber hinaus
unterstützen Sie auch noch mit Partner
wie dem schönen und Aufforstungsprojekte
und verschiedene andere Unterfangen im
Bereich Umweltschutz und Soziales wenn
ich jetzt außer Haus gehe bereitet es
mir daher echte Freude diese Uhr tragen
zu können und damit bin ich nicht
alleine das urige Unternehmen aus dem
Alten Land feiert gerade seinen siebten
Geburtstag und hat mittlerweile fast
eine Million Kunden von der
Attraktivität ihrer Ohren überzeugt zu
diesen zufriedenen Kunden kannst jetzt
auch du und zwar zu besonders günstigen
Konditionen gehören pünktlich zum
Jubiläum möchte Holzkern nämlich auch
unseren Zuschauern etwas Gutes tun und
bietet euch über den Rabattcode Politik
15 bzw im Link die in der Beschreibung
den Video finden könnt einen Rabatt in
Höhe von 15 % an außerdem liegt es noch
ein Poliertuch im Wert von 15 € gratis
dazu also lasst euch diese Gelegenheit
nicht entgehen und tut euch etwas Gutes
natürlich bietet Holzkern auch das
ideale Geschenk für eure lieben mit
einem ebenfalls wunderschön natürlich
gestalteten Schmucksortiment sowie
eleganten Damenuhr so und nachdem ihr
das breite Angebot von Holzkern
ausgiebig durchstöbert hab können wir
wieder zur Beantwortung unserer
brennenden Fragen schreiben wie kann der
Krieg in der Ukraine zu Ende gebracht
werden welches Szenarien haben die
großen internationalen Akteure auf dem
Tisch liegen aufgepasst
besucht wird ein exit
Anfang Oktober 2021 fand ein sehr
wichtiges Treffen im wichtigsten Büro
des Planeten statt dem Oval Office an
diesem Treffen Namen unter anderem
US-Präsident Joe Biden CIA Direktor
Berlin burns und der nationale
Sicherheitsberater des Weißen Hauses
Jacks halleven und der Vorsitzende des
generalstoffs der Streitkräfte general
Marc Militär und was genau war der Grund
für dieses Treffen nur im Grunde
genommen ging es darum die neuesten
Geheimdienst Information zu analysieren
diese deuteten nämlich darauf hin dass
Vladimir Putin kurz vor einem einmal in
die Ukraine stehen könnte wir reden hier
nicht über Vermutungen sondern über
Informationen die Gefahr war absolute
real das war Anfang Oktober 2021 fast 5
Monate bevor die Truppen des Krems
schließlich wirklich in die Ukraine
einmarschiert sind im Rahmen dieses
Treffens wurden wie selbstbestätigte 4
aktionslinien vereinfacht
musste ein bewaffneter Konflikt zwischen
Russland und der NATO um jeden Preis
vermieden werden zweitens sollte im
Falle eines Krieges alles getan werden
um ihn innerhalb der geographischen
Grenzen der Ukraine einzudämmen drittens
waren die Stärkung oder Zusammenhalt der
NATO entscheidend es galt also so
schnell wie möglich das Telefon in die
Hand zu nehmen und viertens und das ist
vielleicht der wichtigste Punkt nicht
nur das Treffen sondern vor allem was
wir seitdem erlebt haben die Ukraine
musste befähigt und mit den Mitteln
ausgestattet werden um sich erfolgreich
gegen eine Invasion Putins zur Wert zu
setzen
ganz genau meine Lieben Zuschauer das
waren nichts anderes als das Treffen bei
dem die Vereinigten Staaten beschlossen
haben dass sie dieses Mal nicht nur an
der Seitenlinie stehen würden wenn
Russland ist Souveränität und Freiheit
der Ukraine verletzen würde dann wären
die Ukraine nicht auf sich allein
gestellt bei diesen Treffen wurde die
Strategie festgelegt die sich in den
folgenden Monaten nach und nach
entwickelte und die zusammen mit der
Solidarität vieler europäischer wie
asiatischer Verbündeter und vor allem
der Hartnäckigkeit Ausdauer und den Mut
der Ukraine dazu geführt hat dass
Vladimir Putin mit Anlauf gegen eine
sehr harte Wand geknallt ist
racing
tiefsten Strom
[Musik]
[Applaus]
KF bleibt frei internationale Verbündete
haben die Ukraine unterstützt insgesamt
haben sie mehr als 160 Milliarden Dollar
an militärischer humanitärer und
finanzieller Hilfe zugesagt eine
gewaltige Summe die die Bedürfnisse des
Landes bis mindestens Ende 2023 decken
soll klar es handelt sich um eine
riesige Summe aber im Vergleich zu den
werthaus der NATO-Länder doch ein
verdammt guter Deal der mit diesen 160
Milliarden Dollar sollen die Bedürfnisse
Ukraine bis mindestens Ende 2023 gedeckt
werden niemand hätte gedacht dass die
Russen im 21 Jahrhundert einen
mittelalterlichen Krieg beginnen würden
dieser Konflikt wird das Gesicht Europas
so sehr verändern wie der zweite
Weltkrieg jamesisch republikanische
Senator aus bei der hau und Mitglied des
nasausschusses für auswärtige
Beziehungen natürlich ist die Tatsache
dass Kief immer noch frei ist eine
großartige Nachricht aber der Krieg die
Zerstörung und die Auslosung von
Menschen leben sind nach wie vor eine
schreckliche Realität die Frage ist also
welche Wege aus dem Krieg herausführen
nur mit diesem Video stellen wir euch
vier Möglichkeiten vor wie der Krieg zu
Ende gehen könnte natürlich sind nicht
alle von ihnen gleichermaßen
wünschenswert oder wahrscheinlich jede
einzelne von ihnen angefangen mit der
ersten ist für alle brutal also
aufgepasst
[Musik]
Szenario Nummer eins Ukraine fallen
lassen
okay rechnete damit dass der Rest der
Welt absolut nichts oder extrem wenig
tun würde außerhalb der obligatorischen
leeren Worte Betroffenheit und so weiter
diese Erwartungshaltung war geschürt
worden durch die lauwarenreaktion des
Westens auf seine Einnahme der Creme und
des don't was im Jahr 2014 und auch das
klägliche Bild das der besten beim Ende
des Afghanistan suggerierte ihm dass er
es mit einem schwachen Decker denten
unterstrittenen Gegner zu tun haben
würde schließlich war dies ja auch die
Botschaft die er über seine Propaganda
sowohl in Russland als auch über seine
fünfte Kolonne im Ausland verbreiten
ließ ja und dann tappte er in jedem
Falle die sich viele narzisstische immer
wieder selbst stellen er fängt an seinen
eigenen Lügen zu glauben er war fest
davon überzeugt dass die internationale
Gemeinschaft tatenlos zusehen würde wie
einem anderen Land das er selbst nicht
als unabhängige national erkennt seinen
Willen aufzwingt und wisst ihr was in
gewisser Weise könnte es dazu immer noch
kommen nehmen wir zum Beispiel sowohl
Trump und seine Folge in den USA oder Le
Pen in Frankreich beide sprechen sich
offen gegen die für die Ukraine aus auch
Trumps erster Konkurrent in der
republikanischen Partei Ron decent ist
hat kürzlich die Unterstützung der USA
für die Ukraine massiv in Frage gestellt
und machen wir uns nichts vor wenn die
westliche Versorgung der Ukraine
unterbrochen würde müsste sie früher
oder später wahrscheinlich kapitulieren
oder bestenfalls einen Waffenstillstand
aushandeln was aber auch einen Sieg für
Putin und eine Katastrophe für die
Ukraine und Europa darstellen würde
tatsächlich ist die kriegsmöglichkeit
des Westens einer der größten Hoffnungen
Wladimir Putins und sie erklärt zu einem
großen Teil warum er immer noch an
seinem Plan festhält genau deshalb war
beides Reise nach Kiew als klares
Zeichen ist Engagements und so großer
Bedeutung die Ukraine aufzugeben würde
bedeuten die Ukraine unter dass sie auch
moskausfall zu lassen oder anders
ausgedrückt sie müssten massenhaft mit
brutalen Repressionen und Säuberungen
aller Art rechnen spricht dem Völker und
Massenmord an tausenden unschuldiger
Zivilisten nur weil sie den Regime
entfernen Moskau nicht genehm sind
hunderte von Leichen gefolterte aus
Botschafter Isi und vielen anderen Orten
stellen ein Schreck liches Beispiel
dafür da was in diesem Fall geschehen
würde aber nicht nur das es wäre auch
katastrophal für den Rest der Welt
denkt mal darüber nach ein solcher Sieg
putils würde allen Tyrannen auf der Welt
zeigen dass sie nicht nur einen
Freifahrtschein haben um zu tun was sie
wollen wann Sie wollen sondern auch das
vollendete Tatsachen und die Politik der
Gewalt die beste Garantie für Erfolg
sind und wenn wir diese Denkweise nun
auf Länder wie Taiwan Korea und
Moldawien und ihre jeweiligen Nachbarn
anwenden haben wir eine Erfolgsformel
für die schlechteste aller Welten eine
Welt in der sich Angriffskriege und
ethnische Säuberungen wieder lohnen und
territoriale Gewinne durch Eroberung
wieder möglich sind ist Putins in
Ukraine the message durch him and over
oder Ladies will be Decken use force to
get what the want
this will make the world Mod Angels an
osmodel genau aus diesem Grund ist diese
Option völlig ausgeschlossen
[Musik]
das bringt uns direkt zum zweiten
möglichen Ergebnis
Szenario Nummer 2 ein eingefrorener
Krieg
zu Beginn erlebten wir die russische
Offensive und dann die ukrainischen
gegenoffensiven aber am ersten Jahrestag
der Invasion schien der Krieg in einer
Art Lethargie zu versinken allerdings
nur aus rein territorialer Sicht denn
die größeren Zusammenstöße beschränken
sich auf ganz bestimmte Punkte wie
bachmut doch der Eindruck trügt trotz
dessen dass ich auf der Färbung der
Landkarte nur wenig ändert hatten wir es
mit den intensivsten Kampfhandlungen des
ganzen Krieges zu tun und was den reinen
Bodycount angeht mit bis zu 1000 Mann
pro Tag wohl auch mit dem
verlustreichsten im bachmut hatten die
ukrainischen Strategen die perfekte
honigfalle konstruiert in dieser sollten
sich die Russen sowohl personell als
auch psychisch und moralisch aufreiben
der Ort war gut selbst hatte dabei weder
für die Ukraine noch für einen weiteren
Vorstoß der Russen eine besondere
strategische Bedeutung wenn er gefallen
wäre hätten sich die Russen eben an der
nächsten Verteidigungsstellung ein paar
Kilometer westwärts weiterhin die Zähne
ausgebissen aber sie konzentrierten ihre
Kräfte aus zwei bestimmten Gründen an
dieser Stelle zum einen weil die Ukraine
aus bachmut be wusst ein Symbol
konstruiert hatte und gleichzeitig Puten
glauben ließ es wäre seine eigene Idee
gewesen erinnert ihr euch noch an unser
Video in dem wir gesagt haben Putin
hätte den Befehl gegeben den Dornbach
bis Ende März 2023 einzunehmen koste es
was es wolle
nun damit ist er auf den ältesten
psychotrick reingefallen den jeder
Staubsaugervertreter drauf hat er hat
den Ukrainern tatsächlich diesen
riesigen maßlos überteuerten
blutstaubsauger namens bachmut mit
Begeisterung abgekauft und er glaubte
dabei auch noch er hätte einen besonders
gutes Geschäft gemacht denn der
Hauptgrund warum die Russen alles
ausgerechnet Nachbar Hut geschickt haben
war auch der dass sie den dortigen
Frontabschnitt noch am besten logistisch
versorgen können es handelte sich nach
den herben Gebietsverlusten im Herbst
ganz einfach um das bequemste
verbliebene Einfallstor in dass sie noch
Truppen und Nachschub zur Eroberung des
westlichen Donners Punkten in unserem
Steiner also Gregorian shindys die
optimale und günstigste Gelegenheit für
einen Durchbruch zu sein der den
Kriegsverlauf endlich zu ihren Gunsten
wenden würden würde schließlich ging es
auch darum sich zu profilieren um seine
wagnertruppe als neue parallel Armee in
Russland zu etablieren man kennt diese
Geschichte ja aus historischen
Konkurrenz kämpfen wie zum Beispiel
zwischen sass und wer macht für den
Diktator geht es das gute alte teile und
herrsche aber wir wissen ja wie das
alles damals ausgegangen ist und auch
jetzt ist es trotz mehrmonatiger
Bemühungen und extrem hohe Verluste
brigoche Zöllner nicht gelungen ihr
Hauptziel die ukrainische Stadt bachmut
einzunehmen infolgedessen gelang es den
kommandieren der regulären Armee
mittlerweile bei Putin immer mehr
Zweifel an den militärischen Fähigkeiten
von Wagner zu sehen ihr hauptkritikpunkt
ist dass ihr Genie Set predigen seine
Ziele statt mit kluger Taktik und
Kampfkunst einfach mit endlosen Wellen
von Rekruten erreichen wollte ihr
kaltblütlich in den Tod schickte im
Gegensatz zu killboards haben aber
Ukraine scheinbar keine
vorkonfiguriertes kill Limit Putin
Entzug deshalb schließlich das Privileg
Häftlinge zurück notieren und schränkte
auch die Waffen Transfers der Armee an
seine Gruppe einbringen ist einfach zu
vielen indiktiere gekommen und hat am
Ende sowieso versagt jetzt schützt ihn
nur noch seine enge persönliche
Beziehung zu Putin reden immer noch bis
zu einem gewissen Grad für nützlich hält
selbst wandte unterdessen dass die
Ukraine bereits 80 man Umbach Mut
zusammengezogen hätten um zum
entscheidenden Gegenschlag auszuholen
und hört euch einfach mal an welche Töne
Putin Chefkoch nun plötzlich von sich
gibt gegen wen kämpfen wir die NATO oder
die Ukraine wir kämpfen ausschließlich
gegen die ukrainische Armee gegen
bestimmte Gruppen psychopathischer
Söldner denen es nur darum geht Russen
zu töten und gegen jene die moralisch
und geistig die Ukraine unterstützen
also um Freiwillige die ukrainische
Armee kämpft natürlich mit großen Mengen
von naturwaffen 24.03.2023
damit widerspricht Gregorian direkt dem
offiziellen narrativ des Kremls aber es
wird noch besser er bezweifelt auch das
Russland überhaupt in der Lage sein die
Ukraine zu entmilitarisieren denn dies
würde die Vernichtung der gesamten
ukrainischen Armee voraussetzen was er
trotz aller laufenden Bemühungen für
unmöglich hält und schließlich versetzt
der Putin in den Muster Propaganda
seines eigenen Chefs noch einen dritten
Tiefschlag die Entnazifizierung der
Ukraine sei ebenfalls illusorisch da
überhaupt nichts von irgendwelchen Nazis
in der Ukraine wisse naja gerade er muss
es ja wissen schließlich ist seine
rechte Hand die truth ein bekennender
Neonazi während eines Einsatzes im
russischen Krieg Bestand dieser darauf
dass seine Einheit wehrmachtshelme trägt
sein Körper ist mit Nazi Tattoos übersät
von sie wohnen der Waffen SS bis zum
Reichsadler mit Hakenkreuz und keine
bete für sich auch den Kampfnamen Wagner
da Richard Wagner der Lieblingskomponist
Hitler
kann man mit bring Ocean baute er dann
die gleichnamige Söldnergruppe auf deren
Zweck darin besteht Putins militärische
Ambitionen in Syrien Afrika und der
Ukraine abseits militärischer
Gerichtsbarkeit umzusetzen sowie ein
Konkurrenz zur regulären russischen
Armee aufzubauen teile und herrsche eben
übrigens bezüglich Wagner und den
militärischen Ambitionen und auch
erfolgen Russland in Afrika Arbeiten im
Moment an zwei speziellen Videos auf die
euch schon in Kürze Freunde wird also
Abo plus Glocke nicht vergessen um sich
zu verpassen aber zurück nach bachmut
natürlich wäre es zurzeit nur reine
Spekulation anzunehmen die Ukraine hätte
mit bachmut absichtlich und gezielt eine
Art Richter geschaffen in die großen
dann massenhaft reinströmen können um an
seinem Ende einen Fleischwolf
vorzufinden aber wenn man die
Psychologie der ukrainischen Strategie
des vergangenen Jahres analysiert muss
man zum Schluss kommen dass dies sehr
wahrscheinlich ist und ebenso
wahrscheinlich ist es dass die Russen in
ihrer Besessenheit und Lernresistenz mal
wieder dermaßen verblendet waren dass
sie darauf hereingefallen sind
andererseits hatten sie auch nicht sehr
viele andere Optionen sie haben
hunderttausende unerfahrene neue
Rekruten in die Ukraine geschickt um
ihre Verteidigung zu verstärken sich zu
verschanzen und so zu versuchen das
eroberte Gebiet zu verteidigen es ist
offensichtlich dass die Verluste die
Russland erlitten hat enorm waren
ukrainische Quellen sprechen von einer
Verlustquote von einem ukrainischen auf
vier russische Kämpfer und beim
Munitionsverbrauch soll die Quote dabei
1 zu 10 gelegen haben ein dermaßen
katastrophales Verhältnis kann sich
selbst eine große Armee wie die
russische nicht leisten für selenski und
seinen kühlkalkulierenden Generalstab
war die der Ukraine geborene Militär
Artikel des abnutzungskrieges deswegen
der Hauptgrund bachmut nicht aufzugeben
aber die Ukraine hat ebenfalls eine
große Anzahl von Opfern zu beklagen
sowohl militärisch als auch zivil und
obwohl sie viele militärische Ausrüstung
aus dem Westen erhalten hat scheint das
immer noch nicht genug zu sein um den
Krieg eindeutig zu gewinnen wenn die
Alliierten ihre Unterstützung aufrecht
erhalten aber den Umfang der Lieferungen
immer weiter reduzieren könnte sich der
Konflikt über Jahre hinziehen und
irgendwann dann sogar ganz zum Erliegen
kommen Ukraine und westliche Medien sind
weitgehend auf sorgfältig gefilterte
Informationen des ukrainischen
Generalstabs angewiesen der seine
tatsächlichen Verluste verschweigt um
die morale Bevölkerung und
Hilfsbereitschaft des bestens nicht zu
untergraben
ich war überrascht wie effektiv die
Ukraine im Informationskrieg sind sie
machen es geschickt es ist keine plumpe
primitive Propaganda sie veröffentlichen
attraktives Filmmaterial von den Kämpfen
was in der Medienwelt wichtig ist es
handelt sich fast immer um Bilder von
Ukrainern die den Russen den Hintern
versohlen das erweckt den Eindruck dass
die Ukraine gut bewaffnet und
ausgebildet sind und über moderne
Ausrüstung verfügen und die Russen
mobilisierte Hinterwäldler die nicht
wissen auf wen sie gerade einschlagen
jeder Kommandeur an der Freund hat mir
bestätigt dass die Russen schlechte
Einheiten haben aber auch gute und bei
den Ukrainern ist es genauso auch bei
ihnen gibt es Pechvögel die eine Woche
Training hatten und nicht wissen was sie
an der Front tun sollen Material ist
tschechische Front Reporter in der
Ukraine
natürlich veröffentlichen auch die
Russen nur ihre schönen zahlen und
Bilder allerdings haben sie nicht so
viele zu Verfügung trotzdem Erschöpfung
Kriegsmüdigkeit der Verlust an
gesellschaftlicher und mediale
Aufmerksamkeit oder die Angst vor einer
weiteren Energiekrise könnten dazu
führen dass viele Länder am Ende nach
einem bequem Ausweg suchen also
versuchen werden den Konflikt
einzufrieren und in gewisser Weise zu
einer Art neuer Normalität
zurückzukehren und wenn Russland eine
neue Offensive starten weitere Gebiete
erobern und dann einen diktatfrieden
anstreben würde ist es durchaus möglich
dass viele Länder Druck auf geht ausüben
werden damit es einwilligt und wisst ihr
was die Ukraine selbst hätte in diesem
Szenario vielleicht keine andere Wahl
als die russische Präsenz auf ihrem
Territorium und das damit verbundene
ständige Gefühle der Angst und
Frustration zu akzeptieren wir
wiederholen immer wieder das Russland
nicht gewinnen darf aber was heißt das
schon wenn der Krieg lange genug mit
dieser Intensität weitergeht werden die
Verluste der Ukraine unerträglich werden
sagte ein hoher französischer Beamter
den Wurst Gutscheine außerdem würde dies
natürlich viel mehr Leid und viel mehr
Ausharren in Ungewissheit für die
Ukraine bedeuten und es ist sicherlich
nicht klar welche Zukunft dieses Landes
in einem solchen Fall überhaupt erwarten
würde könnte die Ukraine wirklich wieder
aufgebaut werden und ausländisches
Kapital und Unternehmen anziehen und
wenn sich das Land technisch gesehen
weiterhin im Krieg mit Russland befindet
wenn ein Teil seines terrierungs besetzt
ist und die Bedrohung durch einen neuen
Krieg weiterhin bestehen bleibt und das
alles scheint schwer vorstellbar zu sein
und natürlich dürfen wir nicht übersehen
dass die ukrainische Wirtschaft schon
jetzt in trömann liegt und Infrastruktur
schwer beschädigt ist mit anderen Worten
dies könnte mittelfristig einen
schleichenden Untergang bedeuten die
Unfähigkeit das Land jemals lebensfähig
zu machen zudem könnte Russland seine
Offensive in ein paar Jahren wieder
aufnehmen wenn die Ukraine schwächer ist
und es auf russischer Seite gelungen ist
ein Teil der Streitkräfte wieder
aufzubauen und sei es nur durch die
Ausbildung neuer Rekruten dies ist ein
echtes und sehr realistisches Risiko
[Musik]
in jedem Fall wäre das in gewisser Weise
eine Sieg für Russland ein weniger
klarer Sieg vielleicht ein führungssieg
aber letztendlich ein Sieg Putin wäre es
gelungen einen großen Teil der Ukraine
zu annektieren und die internationale
Gemeinschaft hätte über die anfängliche
Aufregung hinaus nicht viel getan um
dies zu verhindern
schaut genau hin um zu sehen welchen
Preis Russland für seine Aggression
zahlt und welche Belohnung es erhält was
heute in Europa passiert kann morgen in
Asien passieren jetzt Stoltenberg
Nato-Generalsekretär es steht eine Wende
bevor wie sie seit 100 Jahren nicht mehr
stattgefunden hat und wir treiben diese
Wände gemeinsam
voranbringen zu Wladimir Putin am 22
März 2023 während seine Staatsbesuchs in
Moskau und nimmt euch in acht denn wenn
die Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine
nicht erhöht werden ist dieses Szenario
durchaus wahrscheinlich es bietet vor
allem den besten Ausweg für Russland und
Wladimir Putin persön deshalb verfolgen
einige Verbündete namentlich vor allem
Deutschland und Frankreich zwei Länder
die sich im Krieg nicht besonders
wohlfühlen und ich überlasse es euch die
Gründe zu erraten eine weitere
Alternative ganz genau sie arbeiten an
einer dritten Möglichkeit die Kämpfe zu
beenden aufgepasst
[Musik]
Szenario Nummer 3 Vorbereitung auf 2024
im Jahr 2024 finden auch in Russland
Präsidentschaftswahlen statt deshalb
könnten Putin und sein Gefolge am
meisten daran interessiert sein eine
Lösung des Konflikt vor diesem Datum zu
erreichen damit einen militärischer und
wirtschaftlicher Rückschlag seine
Kontinuität an der Spitze des Krems
nicht in Frage stellen kann das heißt
wenn der Krieg bis zu den Wahlen noch
nicht vorbei ist nun viele russische
Kreise könnten darauf drängen einen
gescheiterten Präsidenten aus dem Weg
zur räumen um einen neuen Führer eines
Bruder zu bringen und sie könnten für
einen solchen planen das formalen Ende
der Amtszeit des russischen Präsidenten
ausnutzen um ein solches Szenario zu
vermeiden könnte Putin bereit sein zu
verhandeln schnell und zugeschnitten ist
zu machen an diese Hoffnung scheint sich
zumindest der französische Präsident
immer noch immer und der deutsche
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz zuklammern
aber damit dieses Szenario möglich wird
muss die Ukraine weiterhin in der Lage
sein Russland zu schaden und das
wiederum erfordert die schnelllieferung
von vielen weiteren Waffen
beispielsweise die Lieferung von
westlichen Panzern wie dem Leopard 2 und
weiterem schweren Gerät was wir jetzt
brauchen ist eine Militäroffensive der
Ukraine die die russische Front
zurückdrängt um den Weg für eine
Rückkehr zu Verhandlungen frei zu machen
Emmanuel macron Präsident Frankreichs
und es ist vielleicht nicht einmal nötig
bis 2024 zu warten
eine ukrainische Offensive im Südosten
jedes also schon mehr erreicht die
gesamte Region saporishias und die
krimin Artillerie Reichweite bringen
könnte bereits ausreichend um eine
Verhandlungslösung zu erzwingen eine
erfolgreiche Offensive dieser Art wäre
der große Wolf für die Ukraine
aber selbst wenn ein Ende des Krieges
ausgehandelt würde könnten wir wirklich
darauf vertrauen dass Russland seinen
Teil der Abmachung einhält nun die
Wahrheit ist dass die Geschichte da
eindeutig ist nein können wir nicht der
Fall der Ukraine selbst ist in der Tat
ein gutes Beispiel dafür vergesst nicht
das Russland in Budapester mit Random
die Sicherheit und vollständiges und
territorial Integrität der Ukraine
einschließlich der Grimm im Gegenzug für
die Aufgabe der ukrainischen Atomwaffen
garantiert hat es wird oft vergessen
dass die Ukraine nach der Auflösung des
Sowjetunion für eine kurze Zeit das am
drittstärksten atomar bewaffnete Land
der Welt war
hätte sich Putin getraut ein solches
Land anzugreifen naja jetzt ist es zu
spät denn sie hat damals ihren
wertvollen Status als atomacht gegen
eine nutzlose russische
Sicherheitsgarantie getauscht und das
heißt als Gegenleistung für mögliche
Friedensverhandlungen würden die
westlichen Länder der Ukraine viel mehr
greifbare Sicherheit geben müssen vor
allem genügend militärische Ausrüstung
und jede weitere russische Aggression in
Zukunft zu verhindern wir sprechen von
modernen gepanzerten Fahrzeugen Raketen
eine Luftwaffe und alles was sonst nötig
ist die Ukraine müsste auf dem Level
eines hochgerüsteten natulandes sein um
sich sicher zu fühlen die Frage ist
jedoch ob dies ausreichen würde wenn
sich Russland mit der Zeit wieder
berappeln und stark genug fühlen würde
er neu zuzuschlagen denn dann hätten wir
den Salat Putin hätte nur wieder Zeit
gewonnen um seinen Schrecken ohne Ende
durchzuziehen und nein dieser Schrecken
müsste mit dem Ableben Putins nicht
enden denn es gibt in Russland genügend
fanatische Nationalisten die in
problemlos ersetzen könnten die dafür
plädieren die Waffenhilfe an die Ukraine
einzustellen und dazu zu zwingen mit
Russland Friedensverhandlungen
aufzunehmen das nämlich völlig außer
Acht dass diese nur dann Sinn machen
würden wenn an ihrem Ende ein
Friedensschluss stehen würde der sein
Papier auch wirklich wert ist und das
heißt jemand muss diesen Frieden
garantieren aber da man sowohl Putin als
auch seine potenziellen Nachfolgern als
friedenskranken erwiesenermaßen kein
Millimeter weit trauen darf müsste es
der besten sein der der Ukraine wirksam
gerannt wird dass sie von Russland
nichts mehr zu befürchten hätte und so
etwas könnte letztendlich effektiv nur
durch die Stationierung westliche
Friedenstruppen oder die Aufnahme der
Ukraine in die NATO umgesetzt werden
aber was würde dann passieren wenn Putin
oder seine Separatisten wieder
irgendwelche Aktion aushecken würden
sein sie für metrisch oder asymmetrisch
was bei ihrer Besessenheit garantiert
irgendwann der Fall wäre ja dann würde
genau das Eintreten vor was ich die
Friedensaktivisten am meisten fürchten
die direkte Beteiligung westliche
Truppen an Kampfhandlungen gegen
Russland oder gar der NATO Bündnisfall
aber wenn wir diese logische Konsequenz
außer Acht lassen im Falle eines
behandlungsfriedens könnte die Ukraine
immerhin versuchen wieder auf die Beine
zu kommen
auf diese Weise könnte die Ukraine
gegenüber Russland abgeschirmt werden
und im Gegenzug für bestimmte
Zugeständnisse in einem Abkommen eines
Zukunft haben dieses Abkommen wäre zwar
extrem schlecht aber wesentlich
akzeptabler als die beiden vorherigen
Szenarien dies zumindest scheint die
Auffassung des Tandems Paris Berlin zu
sein und London scheint es ihren
heutigen Aussagen nach auch nicht als
schlecht anzusehen außerdem würde die
Ukraine auf diese Weise nicht das Risiko
eingehen was ihr 2025 drohen könnte
falls es einen Wechsel im Weißen Haus
gibt dieses Szenario wird von vielen
Beobachtern momentan wohl als das
wahrscheinlichste Ende des Krieges
angesehen allerdings muss man beachten
dass viele dieser Experten zu hier in
der Gruppe gehören die vor und auch
während der Invasion vor allem durch
viel Prognosen auf sich aufmerksam
gemacht haben viel Einschätzungen
bezüglich der Bereitschaft Putins einen
Krieg loszutreten und vor allem die
maßlose Überschätzung der russischen
militärischen Stärke bei gleichzeitige
Unterschätzung der ukraineischen und
diese Tendenz der Realitätsverzerrung
setzt sich nun in ihre Urteilsfindung
bezüglich der Rückeroberung der von
Russland okkupierten Gebiete durch die
Ukraine fort es fällt nun mal schwer das
narrativ mit dem man jahrzehntelang
unterwegs war komplett über Bord zu
werfen und das bestimmte
lieblingsexperten extrem lange voll
daneben liegen können und trotzdem
weiterhin von Entscheidern in Medien und
Politik ernst genommen ja profitiert
werden ist man ja leider auch aus
anderen kritischen Bereichen gewohnt das
Zeitalter der Vernunft scheint eben
immer noch vor uns zu liegen aber kommen
wir zu unserem letzten Szenario denn es
gibt noch einen anderen möglichen Weg
einen der viele Unterstützer in der
Ukraine Polen Tschechien das Slowakei
den baltischen Staaten und auch in den
USA hinter sich vereint wovon ich rede
nun das werden wir uns jetzt ansehen
[Musik]
Szenario Nummer 4 Sieg auf ganzer Linie
das Jahr 2023 begann mit sehr guten
Nachrichten für die Ukraine wir sprechen
über die Zusagen aus dem Westen dutzende
Jahrhunderte von gepanzerten Fahrzeugen
und andere Ausrüstung zu liefern
darunter auch moderne Panzer wir
sprechen von einem Bradleys Strikers
Marder am X10 Challenger 2 Leopard
Panzern Patriot Batterien und so weiter
und so fort wenn diese Lieferungen
fortgesetzt und im Laufe der Zeit sogar
verstärkt werden könnte sich der Verlauf
des Krieges komplett ändern vor allem
wenn mehr heimats mehr Panzer und
Langstreckenraketen geliefert werden
ganz zum schweigen davon wenn die
Ukraine mit mehr und besseren Flugzeugen
und Drohnen ausgestattet würden wenn wir
zurückblicken waren die
Waffenlieferungen zu Beginn des Krieges
sehr zurückhaltend man wollte sich nicht
zu sehr aus dem Fenster lehnen um keine
allzu große Demütigung durch Russland
hinnehmen zu müssen falls die Ukraine
der Herausforderung letztendlich nicht
standhalten würde denn wenn sich die
Ukraine als Unfall erwiesen hätten
während den Russen auch noch die
westlichen Waffen in die Hände gefallen
dies wäre natürlich Putins feuchter
Traum gewesen
wenn er nach einer schnellen
ukrainischen Kapitulation deren
Streitkräfte von damals schon 200.000
Soldaten 250.000 Reservisten und
2596 Panzer in seine Reihen
eingegliedert hätte wäre eine gewaltige
Streitmacht entstanden die in seiner
Vision des großrussischen Reiches von
Lissabon bis vladiwostok ein gehöriges
Stück näher gebracht hätte damit jedem
klar wird wovon hier die Rede ist dass
deutsche Herr zählte damals 63
000 Soldaten und 266 Panzer das
polnische 100.000 Soldaten und 863
Panzer Frankreich hatte 115.000 Soldaten
und 46 Panzer das heißt selbst wenn wir
die Heere dieser drei großen naturländer
zusammenzählen kommen wir auf nur 278
000 Soldaten und
1.535 Panzer das ist weniger als die
Ukraine damals hatte und diese drei
Länder haben keine Wert nicht mehr
können im Ernstfall also kaum
ausgebildeter Wissen mobilisieren
außerdem dürfen wir folgende Tatsachen
nicht vergessen da die fähigkeitsprofile
der EU und NATO Armeen komplimentär
zueinander gelegt sind kann außer der
deutschen Bundeswehr und in Polen keine
von ihnen die nötigen
heereskräftestellen um die Ostflanke der
NATO gegen Russland zu sichern deswegen
wäre es im Ernstfall vor allem auf das
deutsche Heer und seine schnelle
verlegefähigkeit von großverbänden und
die zügigen Mobilisierung von
Reserveeinheiten für wirklich massive
verteidigungsverzögerungs- und
gegenangriffsoperation in der
nordosteuropäischen Tiefebene gegangen
und was soll ich euch sagen kann sich
jemand von euch vorstellen dass die
bundes20 dazu in der Lage gewesen wäre
oder ist vielleicht heute wieder ist es
ergibt daher absolut Sinn dass eine
schnelle Niederlage und eine Aktion der
Ukraine durch die Russen die NATO schwer
beschädigt die eine ernste Notlage
gebracht hätte außerdem wäre infolge
eines solchen totalen Versagens die
Führungsrolle der USA in Frage gestellt
worden mit enormen Auswirkungen auf die
ganze Welt die Grundpfeiler der
Weltordnung wie wir sie kennen in der
wir den Frieden und die Sicherheit in
den westlichen freiheitlich
demokratischen Nationen als gegeben
ansehen während die Dominosteine
umgefallen schließlich war genau das der
Plan Putins und wohl auch seines
Freundes schieb
heute jedoch stehen die Dinge zum Glück
ganz anders vielen Berichten zufolge
könnte die russische Armee erschöpft und
unzureichend ausgerüstet sein das würde
erklären warum es ihnen so schwer fällt
eine richtige Offensive durchzuführen es
stimmt zwar das Russland an wirklich und
mobil machen große Mengen weitere Männer
an die Front geschickt hat und weiterhin
schicken wird aber die Kampfkraft dieser
Einheiten scheint nicht besonders hoch
zu sein schließlich hat die erfolgreiche
Verteidigung bachmuts dazu geführt dass
die Russen ihren Fokus auf die FK
verlagern mussten wo ihnen jedoch nichts
anderes als ein weiteres bachmut droht
aus einer übergeordneten Perspektive hat
die aktuelle russische Offensive also
ihren Höhepunkt überschritten ihr
sowieso schon kläglicher formarsch ist
zum Stillstand gekommen das Problem der
Russen besteht meist darin dass sie im
Gegensatz zu Ukraine einfach nicht
wissen was überhaupt vor sich geht die
Unterschiede zwischen den beiden Seiten
was Ihre Fähigkeiten zur Lage
Einschätzung angeht sind gewaltig
während die Aufklärung der Ukraine im
Zusammenspiel mit der NATO in der Lage
ist selbst relativ kleine Waffen
Transporte wie die der calibors auf der
Krim auszumachen und Meta genau zu
vernichten sind die Russen im Vergleich
dazu quasi darauf angewiesen im
Blindflug zu entscheiden und einfach
drauflos zu kämpfen so konnte die
Ukraine auch viel besser beurteilen ob
sich der Kampf um bachhut für sie
überhaupt lohnt und genau aus diesem
Grund wird sie auch in Zukunft die
Oberhand behalten was die verlustquoten
an Soldaten und Fahrzeugen und die
verbrauchsquoten an Munition angeht denn
genau das ist es ja schließlich worum es
bei einem abnutzungskrieg geht so bitte
und brutal dies auch klingen mag aber
hier müssen sie nun mal durch so lange
Putin nicht nachgibt deswegen könnte
eine Reihe von starken Gegenangriffen
der ukrainischen Armee die russischen
Verteidigungslinien springen mit anderen
Worten es könnte eine Chance geben
Russland zu besiegen und Putins Armee
nicht nur zum Rückzug zuzwängen sondern
die Ukraine komplett zu verlassen
vielleicht mit der einzigen Ausnahme der
Krim aber selbst die Befreiung dieser
Halbinsel ist möglich wenn die
Dominosteine erstmal auf die andere
Seite Umfallen damit wäre der Schaden
für das Putin Regime potenziell eher
Parabel gut die Frage ist nur was wäre
nötig um das zu erreichen nun eine
weitausumfangreichere und
entschlossenere militärische
Unterstützung das Problem die Zeit dafür
drängt immer mehr wie selbst der General
außer Dienst frühere Vorsitzende des
NATO militärausschusses und heutige
Präsident Tschechiens Peter Pavel
betonte eine groß angelegte gegen
Offensive die ist der Ukraine
ermöglichen würde das von Russland
besetzte Gebiet zurück zu erobern sollte
von Kiew innerhalb weniger Monate
gestartet werden es wird extrem
schwierig sein dass derzeitige Niveau
der Militärhilfe nach dem nächsten
Winter beizubehalten die Kriegsmüdigkeit
ist nicht nur auf die Erschöpfung der
menschlichen Ressourcen oder Ausrüstung
oder die Zerstörung der Infrastruktur in
der Ukraine zurückzuführen sondern auch
auf die Ermüdung der Länder die Hilfe
leisten die Vereinigten Staaten werden
sich nächstes Jahr vor dem
Präsidentschaftswahlen im Herbst im
Wahlkampf befinden das muss man in Kauf
nehmen während der
Präsidentschaftswahlen in den USA
richtet sich die Aufmerksamkeit der
Politiker und der Öffentlichkeit vor
allem auf innenpolitische Themen und es
kann gut sein dass das Interesse der
Vereinigten Staaten an der Ukraine
abnimmt Beta Pavel Präsident Tschechiens
gegenüber dem polnischen Fernsehsender
twn aber über den anschwellenden
Wahlkampf um die US-Präsidentschaft
werden wir demnächst einer Reihe
interessanter Videos veröffentlichen
denn hierbei könnte es in der Tat zu
sehr kritischen und entscheidenden
Weichenstellungen kommen und von
chinesischer Seite waren sich ebenfalls
gerade viel an und auch hierüber haben
wir schon mehrere Videos in der Mache
vergesst also bitte nicht visualpolitik
zu abonnieren und auch das Glöckchen zu
aktivieren nur so könnt ihr selbst
sicherstellen die Entscheidung über euer
See Verhalten nicht dem Allmächtigen
Youtube Algorithmus zu überlassen und
dann eventuell eines unserer spannenden
Videos super verpassen denn in der Tat
ist das Risiko dass die Gegner der
Ukraine Hilfe in den USA wieder die
Oberhand gewinnen durchaus real diese
nutzen ja auch immer wieder das allseits
beliebte Totschlagargumente das im Falle
einer schweren russischen Niederlage
Putin einfach einen Atomkrieg vom Zaun
brechen würde aber das ein Atomschlag
für Russland die fatal von allen wäre
haben wir euch bereits in früheren
Videos hier auf visualpolitik dargelegt
und ich werde sie euch verlinken damit
ich hier nicht alles wieder noch mal von
vorne erzählen muss denn wir haben euch
darin genauestens erklärt warum der
Kreml diese Möglichkeit sehr
wahrscheinlich nicht nutzen wird da
dadurch im Grunde genommen absolut
nichts gewinnen aber extrem viel
verlieren würde und zwar viel viel mehr
als selbst durch eine herbe
konventionelle Niederlage ein
hypothetisches Risiko fernab jegliche
Rationalität bleibt natürlich immer
bestehen aber genauso könnte man auf der
anderen Seite zum Beispiel darauf hoffen
dass Putin durch Außerirdische entführt
wird die regelmäßig sich wiederholenden
Atomkriegs Drogen des Krems haben jedoch
einen ganz bestimmten praktischen Aspekt
sie tauchen immer dann auf wenn es den
Russen an der Front ganz besonders
dreckig geht getroffene Hunde bellen nun
mal
25 März 2023 in einer frischen Drohung
an den Westen kündigt Putin an
taktischer Atomwaffen nach Weißrussland
zu verlegen tja könnte es einen besseren
Indikator dafür geben wie die Russen
davor bibbern dass ihre Winteroffensive
endgültig gescheitert ist und die
Ukraine bald wieder die Initiative
übernimmt natürlich würde dieses
Szenario den russischen Diktator gehörig
in die Schranken weisen es ist klar das
ist nicht besonders gut aussieht ein
Krieg gegen ein viel kleineres Land viel
weniger Ressourcen zu verlieren vor
allem wenn die militärische
Modernisierung und die Wiederherstellung
Russlands als starke und große Welt
macht seit mehr als zwei Jahrzehnten die
oberste Priorität des Putin Regimes
darstellt und wenn uns die Geschichte
etwas leer dann das ist für ein Regime
das gerade einen Krieg verloren hat sehr
schwierig ist im Sattel zu bleiben
deswegen fährt Putin und seine
propangeristen immer mehr die Rhetorik
auf das eigentlich nicht die Ukraine ihr
Gegner ist einander gesamte Westen
[Musik]
und wisst ihr was trotz all der Opferung
des alten Schmerzes ist dieses 40
Szenario die Option die derzeit in der
Ukraine die meisten Unterstützer hat
Ukrainisch
Bad
compană
Donald Trump
okay das waren also die vier möglichen
Szenarien wie aus unserer Sicht der
Krieg in der Ukraine enden könnten ihr
seht dass der beste Ausweg in jedem Fall
die Lieferung von der Waffen an die
Ukraine zu sein scheint das scheint
mittlerweile fast jeder verstanden zu
haben sogar oder Scholz aber jetzt seid
ihr an der Reihe welches der von uns
skizzierten Szenarien ist eure Ansicht
nach das wahrscheinlichste oder seht ihr
vielleicht noch weitere Möglichkeiten
die wir nicht erwähnt haben welche
Strategie ist eurer Meinung nach die
beste was würdet ihr tun wenn ihr das
sagen hättet wie immer sind wir auf eure
Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
auch etwas dabei gelernt habt falls ja
gibt uns bitte ein Like teilt und
diskutiert ist mit euren Freunden und
vergesst wie gesagt nicht das aber mit
Glück nur keines unserer Videos mehr zu
verpassen natürlich freuen wir uns auch
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
uns Projekte weiterzuführen den Link
dazu findet ihr in der Beschreibung
unter dem Video macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]